[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here of welcome to the
ninth episode of my queen trap sack
lines in this episode I'm going to show
you one of the high profile Queen
sacrifice line in the nihms Oh Larson /
rating from the white perspective
now before we proceed the important
point I like to mention is the thematic
Queen sacrifice pattern can be arise in
different kind of opening so for example
if you are black then the same pattern
can be applied in Dutch defense
nimzo-indian defense as well as Queen's
Indian defense so by knowing this
important concept you can apply this
tactical idea in various openings
well the opening can be start either
with Knight to f3 or b3 let's say in
this game white goes with proper names o
Larsson achat Mordor starting with B 3
and after D Phi Bishop to b2 immediately
putting their Bishop on a lovely long
diagonal
on the counter part black get the space
on the queenside with C Phi but not to
worry as this opening is more about
peace play rather than approaching to
the center okay III liberating the
bishop and here black and continue with
either of the knight move first let's
say in this game black plays Knight to
f6 first and after the move Knight to f3
he continued eight Knight to c6
well now comes the typical limbs alhasan
pin Bishop to b5 as the LightSquared
bishop is useless in this line more
often and not what is going to exchange
this Bishop with denied and give black a
double bond if it's allowed you should
also note that it is not advisable for
black either to play Bishop to a fire or
Bishop to g4 and the simple reason is
after h3 and G for white get tremendous
space and attack on the Kings side which
can create some nasty problems to the
black camp so accordingly the best
response is Essex however it allows this
to mattock attacking John Knight to e5
pressurizing c6 so Quinn to c7
is obvious response protecting and after
Castle black complete his King side
development with an attack with Bishop
to b6
white certainly do not want to move the
night so he has to continue it fo and
after blacks obvious response castle
which unpin the c69 the sister right
time to lop it off and when black
recapture here comes the starting point
of our Queen sacrifice line rook to f3
and now you can see the important of the
f4 move that rook is going to swing on
the Kings side and create some nasty
problems to the black cam now in the
database all the games continue it
Knight to d2 which is a very logical
response black wants to undermine that
night as quickly as possible so that way
white attack can be slowed down
so what do you think guys should remove
the night well of course not as when we
are attacking we should more concentrate
on the attacking aspect and accordingly
rook to h3 is a fitting reply
so what planning is very simple we want
to play Queen to h4 and checkmate the
guy on the g8 so something which black
needs to pay attention immediately
if epics then night captures d7 and I
think position is slightly better for
the white camp and the other move namely
capturing on e5 doesn't provide any
solution to the black game as after the
simple reply Queen to h5 threatening a
checkmate so at six is forced and after
that this simple trading sequence Bishop
captures e5 bishop kept c5
Queen captures ePHI Queen capture c5 and
the move F captures ePHI if you count
the remaining material on the board not
only black has a double pawn on the C
file but there is a huge difference in
terms of minor piece as black has this
bad bishop sitting on c8 where White has
this good night and any endgame expert
knows that this position is quite
favorable to the white cap
so considering all these things in few
games black indeed played the mood g6
which is the obvious response stopping
Queen to h5 idea by wide and same time
pressurizing the e finite so what can be
the more natural than this
well everything is so good for the black
except one problem that the last move is
a big time blunder by a black camp and
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a killing more
here which finish up the black instantly
you
well I hope you indeed see this
beautiful Queen sacrifice oh what a move
ha ha ha
to be honest the first time when I see
this move I said hang on that is not
even possible but more you look at it
more you find how amazing this move is
the first important point is what is
threatening at 7 checkmate and if black
foolishly captured this Queen then after
rook to g3 check King to achieve and
Knight captures f7 it's a lovely double
discovered checkmate
so this option is right out of the
window in the game black plays the only
defensive move Knight to f6 which keeps
everything in under control but after
White's next reply black simply resign
so the last time guys I want you to
pause this video and find out a decisive
move which forced black to give up the
game immediately
yup you are absolutely right
if you find this star mu of the game
Knight to g4 and back and pack his bag
and go home
why what happens if he captured the
Queen now well let's check out the fast
move Knight captures edge fire is a
pretty bad wound and I think you already
see it right night 26 wonderful smothers
mate so that's not even possible
and what happens if G captures H fire
now well I think this is the only
critical line and even after the
complication white emerge with a clear
of winning advantage so the sample line
can goes like this Knight to f6 check if
King to g7 the night to eat is a very
strong reply so more or less King to H
it is forced and now comes Luke captures
h5 threatening rook captures at 7
checkmate and to award this Black has
the only mu in this position namely at 6
and here comes the discovery my captors
defy unleashing the chat to the black
king and the same time regaining the
Queen back and when black take this
piece we are going to chop up one more
pond with rook capture c5 and at the end
of the whole sequence if you carefully
shed the material at this point white is
a clear tree pond advantage which with
accurately more than sufficient to win
the game
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful Queen sacrifice in
the limbs Oh Larsen attack remember if
you reach this position in the
tournament practice shock your opponent
with this deciding blow Queen to h5 and
after this no matter how River black
plays he get completely losing position
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment on
this video and I will meet you in my
next episode very soon bye and take care